hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Japanese action thriller
film called usogi spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
Baku matarame is a prolific Gambler who
goes by the name of usogi he is regarded
as Invincible by many that is until he
meets his match one day the film begins
on a skyscraper in Tokyo where Baku and
the 21st generation Royal leader of the
kikaru club suichi kiruma are gambling
the kakaru club is Japan's largest
gambling organization which supervises
many large steak games the members for
the club are picked from the country's
highest political rankers which means
that these members have the power to
pull the strengths of the national
government the Arrogant Baku challenges
so Ichi by betting his life on the line
if he wins he wants soichi's position as
the leader of the kakeru club without
speaking a word the latter agrees
meanwhile the gambling is moderated by
two Club referees including hikoichi
yako rumor has it that they have never
been impartial in their lifetimes after
consuming a biscuit Baku bets that
within an hour at least 1 plane will fly
by their location unfortunately for him
so Ichi is so powerful that he secretly
orders his henchmen to take control of
all the flights in Japan and divert them
away from their current location it's
also revealed that Baku had hired some
Pilots to fly by their location before
the game but they are immediately
assassinated by soichi's people as a
result no planes are seen by the
predicted time limit and Baku loses the
game too bad Baku didn't bet on birds
instead however just when he is about to
be finished off the club referee hikochi
informs Baku that his execution is
revoked instead he will be stripped of
his club membership and exiled to a
remote location outside of Tokyo the
movie then fast forwards by three years
somewhere in a remote Village a bunch of
men are seen gambling one of them an old
man who has been on a winning streak for
two hours the others are perplexed as to
how he is winning every single game
despite the odds being equal for
everyone shortly after Baku shows up and
confidently gambles 1 million yen
stating that he will eat the old man's
lies that's hardcore to everyone's
surprise he immediately wins the bat and
exposes the old man's deception to the
rest of the group Baku breaks a dice and
reveals a hidden magnet inside of it he
also shows the number of magnets that
were hidden under the table they were
altering the dice's position helping the
old man win every single time ah so
that's how magnets work it's then
revealed that Baku had also placed a
magnet inside the 1 million yen he had
bet this eventually swung the tie in his
favor winning him all the muns later
during lunch Baku meets one of his
friends who tells him that there is an
uproar in Tokyo as one person wants to
beat soichi the leader of the kakeru
club he informs Baku that the person is
a scientist named iki sarakuni who is
widely popular in Tokyo this is because
of his latest breakthrough of
discovering and Mining a new element
called methane hydrate an energy that
can be used to replace oil it turns out
iki had invested all of his funds in his
research without the government's help
however after one fatal explosion killed
all the research members he suddenly
vanished from the public eye but
according to some sources icky is now
targeting the kakario club in mainly
soichi to become the next leader this
makes Baku yearn to return to the city
so that he can settle his past the scene
then cuts to a gambling match between
the Finance Minister Masahiro onodera
and the scientist icky which is overseen
by a club referee named KIRO makama it
turns out that Masahiro is the one who
challenged icky so that he could
hopefully control the next election by
exploiting icky's research findings
however icky manages to win all six
betting rounds in a row causing Masahiro
a massive loss of 300 million yen
humiliated he orders the referee to
restart the game which is against the
rules in the kakaru club when KIRO
declines Masahiro orders his men to kill
him fortunately the ref has exceptional
combat skills and he easily kills The
Minister's men after the massacre KIRO
approaches ziki and asks to be his
personal referee meanwhile Baku arrives
in Tokyo where on the streets he meets a
young boy named takaomi Kaji Kaji is a
kind-hearted boy but he has his problems
too he was cheated on by his friends
because of which he had to borrow money
from dangerous Loan Sharks as they talk
on a bench Kaji is suddenly confronted
by the lone sharks who threatened him
for money fortunately Baku scares them
off by lying that he is a part of the
Yakuza he then asks Kaji how much debt
he owes in total and the latter replies
2.2 million yen feeling sorry for the
boy Baku offers to assist him the same
evening the two enter an illegal Casino
owned by a woman named renko Kurama and
gamble all the money they have on
roulette Baku purposely bets his coin
chips on all the numbers except to the
ones chosen Kaji calls the idea foolish
saying that they will lose more coins
this way however Baku increases his bad
amount confident that they will win
everything unfortunately Kaji has proven
to be right Baku loses the round but he
still doesn't look even a bit worried
instead he decides to go all or nothing
after all being a good Gambler is the
same thing as being an insane idiot for
the final round Baku increases his wager
and bets on every number besides nine he
then eats a biscuit and seeing this Kaji
immediately gambles all of his money on
the number nine turns out everything is
a part of their plan before they started
playing Baku had told Kaji to bet all of
his money into the number that he hadn't
chosen once he ate the biscuits the plan
works and the duo wins the game and
earns around 5 million yen Baku gives
the money to Kaji so that he can pay off
his debts and continue his life after
the game Kaji develops a liking for Baku
and asks to be his accomplice however
the prolific Gambler doesn't want to
endanger kaji's life so he declines the
same evening icky gambles inside
karama's illegal casino and beats her in
a game without much fuss Baku is also
among the crowd and he quickly
challenges ikki to a game of their own
however the latter declines the
challenge as Baku is not a member of
kakaru Club desperate for a rematch Baku
approaches Kurama and pleads for her
kakaru membership but as expected she
refuses instead she directs him to a
person that is willing to gamble their
club membership the person is an old man
and a psychopath named taru kakone in
the next scene Kaji approaches Baku and
begs to be a sidekick this time the
latter surprisingly agrees so the next
day the two meet Taro who takes them to
his house inside his own private Forest
Taro explains that for their game Baku
and Kaji must obtain five keys from five
of his pets within a certain amount of
time if they win they will earn 10
million yen the game will be supervised
by none other than hiko ichiako the
famous referee from the kakaru club
however before the game begins Baku
challenges Taro for his kakeru
membership the old man thinks for a
while and agrees out of Pride filled
with joy Baku gifts hikoichi a pen but
unbeknownst to them it is a listening
device shortly after the game begins and
the two boys find out that taro's pets
are actually mercenaries they aren't
even equipped with high-end weapons but
despite this Baku and Taro managed to
defeat and capture them using the
listening device annoyed Taro unleashes
his Ultimate Weapon a muscular human
named rodem who turns out to be his
biological son it is revealed that rodem
has been subjected to a series of
experiments turning him into a powerful
monster however he has one weakness
which is that rodem falls asleep after
every 15 minutes Baku gets wind of this
through the listening device so he plans
to stall rodem long enough until he
falls asleep the two then enter a
warehouse and find a bottle of methanol
to use as a weapon shortly after they
use the bottle to Blind and restrict
rodem's movements he struggles for a
while and eventually falls asleep
resulting in Victory for the boys they
obtain Tara's members ship and hikoichi
congratulates Kaji on becoming an
official member of the katario club here
it is finally revealed why Baku let Kaji
join him as an accomplice he wanted to
gain the club membership via his
accomplice as his past with the club
rendered him unable to do so the next
day Baku returns to the forest and takes
rodem under his wing turns out the brood
is actually a kind person who just needs
some love Baku changes his name to Marco
promising to teach him some gambling
tricks later the scene then shows a
flashback to icky's past where he meets
with the Finance Minister Masahiro
onodera and tells him that he wants to
share his methane hydrate Discovery with
the rest of the world for free however
Masahiro strictly refuses claiming the
product is dangerous for the general
public to possess to make himself clear
he installs explosives in icky's lab and
destroys the entire place the incident
killed several scientists and although
icky survived he was rendered
permanently blind now his only mission
in life is to take revenge against the
government icky did some intensive
research and came to the conclusion that
becoming the leader of the kikeru club
would be the easiest way to take down
the corrupt government officials one by
one in the present he finally accepts
baku's challenge to attract media
attention the movie then cuts to their
match day which is broadcasted live and
is witnessed directly by many state
Elites including Karama as Baku and Kaji
enter the gambling Arena the latter is
spooked by icky's new assistant KIRO as
a result he accidentally fires his
weapon damaging one of the CCTV cameras
inside after a while hikoichi requests
the audience watching the game live to
participate by investing money as a bet
for any player who wins in addition the
investors also determine what sort of
punishment the losing player will have
to bear surprisingly in a matter of
minutes the total sum of money bedded
amounts to 2 billion yen following this
the investors also decide that the
resulting punishment will be hangman
where the losing player and their
partner will be hanged in front of the
live audience in inside the gambling
Arena good thing Kenny and Spenny never
thought of that one so Baku and Nikki
play a gambling game called hangman old
maid in which two players take turns
taking cards from the opponent's deck in
order to look for the same matching card
as a result any player who receives an
old maid card at the end of the game is
immediately declared a loser of that
round however in this particular game
The Old Maid cards have numbers ranging
from one to five and the number chosen
determines the number of parts to be
assembled for The Gallows so any player
who receives Old Maid cards 11 times
will also lose before the game starts
hikoichi announces that any sort of
cheating or underhanded techniques are
allowed as long as the opposing player
is unaware so without any delay the game
begins and in the first round icky wins
as Baku receives an old maid card worth
five in the next round he gets another
old made card worth four totaling his
amount to nine Parts assembled for The
Gallows meanwhile Kaji and Kurama are
anxious as they are sure that Baku will
lose the game to their horror he pulls
another Old Maid card with this Baku is
only one card away from getting himself
and Kaji hanged however Baku is
determined to turn the tables around and
in the final round he eats his special
biscuit it is then revealed that despite
being blind icky can see his opponent's
cards through the CCTV cameras all
around the gambling Arena when Baku
comes to know of this he uses the blind
spot which was created when Kaji
unintentionally damaged one of the
cameras as the game progresses on he
even peeks through icky's cards as
everything is fair in this game at last
he draws a made card with a pen and
shows it to the camera icky's brain
perceives that his opponent is lost and
so he jumps in Joy unfortunately this
only exposes his fraudulent plan in
front of the referee and the entire
audience it turns out he had installed a
device into his back with the help of
which his brain could see everything
happening via CCTV Furious from the
defeat the assistant KIRO tries to
attack Baku but hikoichi effortlessly
kills him witnessing this icky accepts
his fate and officially grants Baku his
kakaro club membership he is then
finished off as per the rules of the
game in front of everyone the movie then
skips one year into the future where
Baku Karama Marco and Kaji travel to a
place for a gambling game shortly after
arriving they are greeted by hikoichi
who takes only Baku inside an arena the
movie ends as it is revealed that Baku
will play against soichi Kurama for the
position of the leader of the kakeru
club subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching